[Music]
hey you guys time once again for the
matinee show this is episode 70 yeah one
thing that I'm going to do someone sent
me a message earlier this week and said
that what for whatever reason like when
we first started the show when we first
started doing the regular episodes and
then we started doing the movie
retrospectives I had started doing like
audio versions of those and like putting
them in you know in the very streams
that will come out on iTunes and stuff
like that and for whatever reason when
we started doing the matinee show I just
never got around to doing an audio
version of it so it didn't really occur
to me until somebody sent me a message
earlier I was like hey I listen to you
on iTunes and you know you bring up like
the matinee show and the and the
witching hour show like the scary
stories and it's like I don't have those
or are they on a different channel so I
said well maybe I'll start to upload
audio versions of them as well so yeah
just to get like a larger I don't know
why I didn't start doing that I guess
cuz the matinee show when we started it
out we started recording it like we were
recording it at the theater yeah and so
it really didn't seem that didn't make
it it didn't really make sense just to
do an audio version of it but now that
we do it like you know like a more
traditional show so I'll probably just
start doing that and just putting that
in a stream just like I usually do with
the other stuff okay so now that that's
out of the way let's talk about some new
movies new ish movies in one series so
we'll do two that we're on Netflix and
we'll do one that was in the theater
it's the first one they're going to talk
about is a Netflix
true-crime miniseries called killer
inside the mind of Aaron Hernandez yeah
this is a good series I remember when
this happened
see I can't remember anything about this
because it's like you know it yes it's a
crime and everything like that but the
guy was you know the murderer was a
professional football player and I fell
football player for the New England
Saints right and no nope a Patriots
offense yeah I'm not in D&E this will
I'm not either than all right should I
give a [ __ ] about balls of scrubs bomb
you know if you want to watch sports
ball and bra man [ __ ] playing with
balls and [ __ ]
that's all right you can do that I'm not
into it this is a story of damp our top
I know a lot of people like me talk
about power to better daddies and power
bottoms [ __ ] and jump on your
ass first
this guy here man was a power top anyway
anybody to know he was in a closet
he was my oh your ass behind the house
yeah it was pretty think about this it's
basically like I said if you don't know
the broad outlines of the story this is
about Aaron Hernandez who I said played
for the New England Patriots as
professional NFL player and in 2013 he
murdered his friend and also his
fiance's sister's boyfriend yeah
whose name was Odin Lloyd yet he would
do it for like just because he got mad
he couldn't control himself he had a
bunch of head injuries that's par as
wrong yeah and I think lightin he was
paranoid when they go into like a lot in
this and I mean some criticism of this
that I've seen was that you know they
don't ever actually like come to a
conclusion of what like caused it but I
don't think that was really the point of
the series I think the point of the
series was like examining kind of all of
the aspects of his life and his
background and stuff like that and what
might have contributed to him being the
way that he was the weird thing about is
he wasn't like a serial killer type
thing even though he was convicted of
killing Odin Lloyd because he wasn't a
master criminal or anything it wasn't
like anything was really thought out
before him like he just he left [ __ ]
tire tracks and footprints and was all
spur-of-the-moment yeah it just it just
seemed like it to me the moment he did
he didn't have any impulse control which
is what I think what his problem was
so it kind of like went a little bit
into that now it goes into I I guess
like with the guy that made this he
initially was making it as just like a
regular documentary but then Netflix got
interested and they're like hey you want
to expand that to like a miniseries now
in the original documentary they didn't
really talk about Aaron Hernandez being
in the closet that only came about later
when his childhood friend you know came
out and said that you know we had a
sexual relationship from you know 7th
grade until you know high school or
whatever
was so they are speculating that him
being you know either gay or bisexual
and trying to keep it a secret might
have been one of the things that was
making him like insecure or making
because it really did seem like he had a
lot of anger issues like well behind the
scenes during his trial as he said that
that's what it was yeah what I remember
didn't didn't wasn't his lawyer arguing
that behind the scenes to to I I really
you know I was I've been drinking at
that time well the thing about it though
is it's interesting because the lawyer
that defended him who actually um was
interviewed extensively for this yeah
after he saw the documentary he was kind
of bummed out about it because he's like
I didn't mean to imply that that was
what was that that was what caused his
because he clearly had a lot of other
problems as well I think really that
might be the main and I and I liked that
in the third installment they kind of
went a lot into into CTE and you know
talk to you know the doctors
neurologists they talked about other
football players that you know had
started playing very young and the
effect of getting whacked in the head
multiple times over years and years and
you know they they even showed like some
you know brains and things like that of
people that had died of it you know
other football players and stuff and
showing like the difference but like I
said the interesting thing about this
was that um as I said I didn't know
anything about this case um so it was so
I didn't you know I didn't know how it
was gonna end I didn't know what was
gonna happen so to me it was like really
kind of a fascinating journey how it
just kind of got you know the murder of
Odin Lloyd like which happened very
early like in the first part in the
first part of the series but then it
just kept growing all these tendrils
it's like they're speculating that a
year before Odin Lloyd was killed that
he might have killed two other people
just like in a drive-by
yeah what's weird is just dude had
millions of dollars a week I was yeah
yeah like 40 million dollars on track he
had all the money you'd ever want but he
wanted to run around sell drugs and
and he wanted to be a gangster yeah he
had delusions agiels had delusions of
black he wanted to be black yeah he was
white but he was really trying to be a
black gangster if you ask me
yeah none of my black dudes not gangster
black dudes and [ __ ] and he tried to
[ __ ] wanted to fit in with that
culture yeah I guess he did he's killing
people is putting gangsta gang tattoos
on himself and he had em unlimited money
you don't need to do all that he didn't
he didn't need to [ __ ] sell though
that's what made this you wanted
fascinating look like I said I don't I
know that they kind of spun off in a lot
of different directions oh maybe he
smoked too much weed oh maybe he had CTE
maybe he was a closeted gay and that
made him like really insecure and he was
trying to be like super macho you know
maybe his dad was abusive and you know
his dad died when he was very young and
that probably affected him and stuff too
but you know it they don't focus on one
thing but I think that's good because I
think this was a very complicated story
and I think that was the thing that
fascinated me the most about it was that
why would somebody who was this
successful I mean you know he went to
college he played for the Gators here in
Florida you know probably the best
college you know program in the country
and he played for them and did really
well but like you know the [ __ ] that he
got up to off the field you know he sort
of had a reputation for being really
hot-headed being really impulsive and
even though he got away with a lot of
stuff that he did while he was in
Florida it did seem like you know when
when they were doing like the draft
picks or whatever like for the
professional teams he didn't get picked
to like the fourth round even though he
was one of the most popular ones that
everybody wanted and stuff and they're
speculating that that was probably
because of his reputation of being like
difficult or you know that he couldn't
really control his temper well he got
out and when he got in prison though it
came out that he was you know I had a
boyfriend up in there and then that all
the stuff came out after his trial and
he said [ __ ] it he he was in prison he
killed himself
yes and he got out and I don't
understand what the [ __ ] problem was
he had life imprisonment he wasn't going
anywhere
he was already
they weren't gonna say anything to him
you know I mean and and he's already in
prison yeah you know I mean it's like
who cares if it's gay he [ __ ] will
yeah that's the thing it's like I feel
like sometimes dudes in the prison in
there or making men into other women
what the hell I don't really see what is
she welcome Ivana he had some kind of
self-loathing he did I think that was
the problem more than in you know to us
to a smaller extent I think that still
you know the NFL in particular even now
like even in 2020 I don't you know I
don't watch football I don't know like a
lot about that but it does seem like
it's still a little bit backwards and
how it approaches that kind of thing
just from some of the interviews that
they had with some of the other
professional players that had come out
later on and saying you know it's still
very much like you know everyone has to
be manly man and you have to like keep
your kind of sexuality under wraps a
little bit because it's still not as
accepted as maybe it is in society at
large so whatever it was and I think
Aaron Hernandez too like I think the
problem was that his father was very
manly man macho
you can't ever do anything girly or
anything like that he was very much like
that so I think that he maybe kind of
internalized that maybe the only thing
that I would complain about and I think
this happens with a lot of true crime
series is that they focus a lot more on
the killer obviously than they do the
victim this one's a little better in
that regard they actually do talk a lot
about Odin Lloyd they talk to a lot of
his friends because he was a football
player as well semi-pro and so so they
do go into that some and then like after
Aaron Hernandez's suicide at the end
they talk about Odin Lloyd's family
because I guess it happened in
Massachusetts and/or he was convicted in
Massachusetts and they had this really
weird like a very very arcane law on the
books that if you had been convicted of
murder but you died before your appeal
could go through then they would
essentially like scrub the conviction
and you would you know they weren't
proving guilt you like you weren't
proven guilty because your appeal hadn't
done you would die before your appeal
and so Odin Lloyd's family was very and
understandably upset about that because
he said oh well now his murder is like
technically unsolved
because even though the guy got
convicted so I liked that they ended it
with Odin Lloyd's family kind of like
trying to get that law changed and I
believe they did successfully get it get
it changed so that that wouldn't happen
again you know they said we know it
won't bring him back obviously but we
wanted his murder to be solved and we
wanted him to you know Aaron Hernandez
down as the killer and stuff like that
but it was like a really interesting
like I like I said I don't know anything
about football this is very football
centric there's a lot of work for there
yeah there's a lot of sports ball stuff
well I don't there sports ball sport is
whatever sounds about today okay I'm not
gonna bag on sports just from my from my
point of view you know I'm 50 all right
maybe I'm ahead of the game or whatever
but sports ball was something like your
dad was interested in yeah yeah I mean I
didn't really yeah my dad was my dad was
my dad was more than a scar but yeah
yeah they'd be in there you hear the
[ __ ] television Wow yeah man ounce
we're talking all day thanks ox
thank you sir no I mean I said I used to
really really hate like when I was a kid
with like the the noise of the sports
come in from the TV and they did you
shoot he did and I'm looking I'm like I
don't give a [ __ ] yeah I had relatives
that were really really into football
particularly you know that we're into
the Gators and stuff like that that's
why I kind of knew a lot about that
because they were into that but it's
like yeah it was never anything I was in
DC there so there is a lot of football
stuff in this because you know obviously
he was a popular player and you know so
there's like a lot of footage of him
playing and a lot of like [ __ ] about you
know how his career was good but I think
that was good to establish you know for
somebody like me that doesn't know [ __ ]
about it how popular of a player he was
how well-regarded he was which you know
just to juxtapose it against why the
[ __ ] would he just go around shoot
allegedly shooting two people in a car
just because they spilled a drink on him
allegedly he didn't get convicted of
those two but one guy that he shot in
the face and lived did actually say that
he had done that and that was the reason
he had done to like somebody had just
pissed him off they never really did
determine
why he had killed Odin Lloyd there was a
little bit of speculation over what the
motive might have been but remember
we're just talking about show or not
yeah we're not doing a show on this guy
right yeah I know okay yeah I'm just
saying yeah it's on over into show mode
you know if you're into Netflix if
you're in a true-crime and stuff like
that this probably it's not the best
true crime series I've seen on there but
it is like a really good one and it's
definitely worth watching like I said
it's it's fascinating to me how this guy
who like I said at all this money
he has like his fiancee he had a baby
and all this other kind of stuff and
then like he would just go around doing
this stupid [ __ ] like you said I think
he kind of had delusions of gangster
yeah I think that might have been a
problem too and I think he definitely
had some head injury issues and some
other psychological issues too but yeah
so it's on Netflix if you're into true
crime it's only about three three and a
half hours long something like that if
you want to we just watched it all in
one night but yeah I found it really
interesting even if you're not into
sports ball
you
all right the second movie we watched
this week was also on Netflix it
actually came out I think it was at a
sin apocalypse Film Festival back in
summer of 2019 but I just got around to
watching it on Netflix it's called dead
con now this movie is kind of like it
you can tell that it's a moshing The
Shining in that it's set in a hotel it
has kind of like a Scatman Crothers type
of character you know there's a haunted
room and all this other kind of stuff
but it has to do with its taking place
during I guess a convention called view
con which I guess is supposed to be like
VidCon which is like the convention of
like all the youtubers and stuff like
that or influencers or whatever the [ __ ]
they call them so I think that the two
main women there in this like the two
main actors I think they are both actual
like big popular YouTube youtubers even
though you know it's not really my
that's not really my demographic so I
don't really know I didn't know that
prior to like watching the movie so
basically what the setup of this movie
is there's kind of a prologue where in
this particular hotel room in 1984 there
was this guy who was trying to develop
what looked like some kind of like proto
internet chat group or something like
that I think it's called rabbit blink or
something and it either gained sentience
or there's somebody at the other end
like making him murder children to be
friends with him or something like that
I wasn't like real clear on that yeah it
wasn't this is one that I watched for
about five minutes and then started
checking out mentally and just go just
kind of put up with it you know gotta be
honest yeah gotta be honest and that and
I remember very little of this but the
problem with it was well okay a couple
things that I liked about it like the
design of the hotel rooms and stuff like
that were really cool like I think that
they were like kind of retro looking
which I really dug the cinematography
was really cool so you can tell like a
lot of thought was put into that one of
the main problems though
and you know maybe this is just me
because you know I'm old and everything
but it's like the the characters at the
center of it you know being YouTube
influencers they tried to like the main
girl whose name was I think her screen
name was like eh aka Ashley or something
like that um they tried to give her like
something of a character art because
she's come to this convention and she
has you know millions of subscribers who
appear to be mostly like tween girls and
you can tell she's kind of [ __ ] over
it and she just doesn't want to do this
anymore and she's getting really tired
and she wants a vacation so it's like
that you know they did try to like
establish some character with her and
her like assistant or psycho it must be
nice having an assistant but yeah so but
the problem though is that the
characters just come off as very shallow
and narcissistic and unlikable I mean
particularly the one character's
boyfriend who I guess is supposed to be
unlikable so okay fair enough but it's
like all of these people I mean other
than one guy in there who's like pretty
okay even though he does some
questionable [ __ ] most of the people are
just like really vapid and really not
that relatable to me and like not that
likable that may have been the idea so
yeah so if they were indeed trying to
make a point about how horrible these
people were then kudos because you did
good I'm not sure if that's what they
were trying to do and maybe they were
because there were a couple of like kind
of jokey like in Joe kind of stuff there
was like a couple of funny scenes in
there that I really liked but the unlike
ability kind of like distanced me a
little bit from it I'm not saying that
it's like a bad movie I actually kind of
enjoyed it like I said it looked really
cool I liked the concept although I wish
that it would have been fleshed out more
because like I said there is some
there's something going on in this
particular room you know normally people
don't stay in this room because
apparently everybody that works there
knows that it's haunted or whatever but
because this convention is so packed and
like you know this one girl's assistant
like flips out because they double
booked a room and she doesn't have a
room now and also
kind of stuff so they end up putting her
in there when they normally wouldn't and
then there's a hole like I said the
whole thing with like this guy having
made like this proto internet thing and
I'm not really sure like where like
there's ghost children in there or
something or I think what the thing was
was that I think that his program became
sentient and then like it was a kid but
it wanted the guy to like bring him
friends so he started like murdering
children so the children's souls could
go into the thing I I guess I'm just
saying that it wasn't really yeah if you
have to if you have that you know I read
it but that maybe that's not what the
intention if you have to guess then that
means that the story is not well told
it's just just maybe so I'm just saying
yeah so this next one you know we're
talked about okay wait so that axon yeah
I didn't really understand the story but
this one it's like I I get what they
were going for I just wish I mean that's
how I read it maybe you could read it a
different way but I just wish that had
been explained like a little bit more
that said there was some cool kills in
it it's like I said the cinematography
was cool like some of the imagery was
creepy and you know all that other kind
of stuff but I think that and it was
even kind of interesting from a point of
view of you know these youtubers that
are you know 21 22 year old women and
all their fans are like these little
girls and then you know they have all
this fame and all these subscribers and
it's like they have to be on all the
time cuz they're always like vlogging
from the place and you know how that
would kind of wear on you after a while
I guess because you know they have like
there was like a lot of scenes like
these little girls like running through
the halls and like screaming and
knocking on everyone's doors and stuff
and so you could see how being that kind
of famous would start to wear you out
after a while but I wish that had been
explained explore it a little bit more
it just seemed like a very kind of
surface-level kind of movie like nothing
wrong with it but it was just kind of
forgettable you know what I mean yeah I
don't even remember the movie yeah he's
like he was just kind of like
half-assedly washed it you know what I
should if you don't catch me in the
first few minutes then you lost me and
when I told him what maybe worried he
was like dude did I even watch
it's only like a few days ago sound like
I said it's it's not a great movie but
it's you know if you're into that kind
of thing if you like to see horror
movies based around new media like you
know it wasn't as good as say something
like unfriended which was actually like
much better than I was expecting but if
you like things in that vein you might
like it but I don't know or maybe open
windows although I like I liked that one
better but um this one I I think the
unlike ability that characters was like
the main I liked the concept I liked the
cinematography I liked the way it was
done I just the characters there was
really no one for me to care about or
root for it's like most and were just
annoying and I was just waiting for them
to get killed which you know that's kind
of a shame but yeah it's like alright if
you got nothing better to do I guess
check it out of necklace
you
all right the third movie we saw this
week was in the theater this was Gretel
and Hansel yeah this was gonna be
interesting to talk about here this was
like okay now this was directed by Oz
Perkins who fun fact was the son of
Anthony Perkins this is actually his
third movie and I really loved his first
two which were I am the pretty thing
that lives in the house and the Black
Codes daughter now if you like those
movies you might dig this one as well
this is a very strange movie like I I
hadn't really heard much about it like
coming out and then like a while back we
saw a trailer for it I was like oh
actually that looks pretty cool it looks
it reminded me is this kind of be a
weird thing to say but it reminded me a
little bit of the original system the
ridge '''l Suspiria and the Suspiria
remake had kind of like been squished
together you know I mean it gave me that
kind of vibe and yeah he's a witch
ologist yeah I write books about him and
everything yes so I and I love like old
school witches and I love like stuff
that's like based on old fairy tales and
things like that especially if they're
done really dark and everything so I was
kind of intrigued by the premise of this
and like I said I really liked this
directors other two movies even though
I'd only seen one trailer so we went to
see it and this was it I think you put
it but you put this is like kind of a
mixed bag um one thing it's actually
like I was expecting it to be more of
cos didn't I think a few years ago they
made like a Hansel and Gretel witch
hunters thing that was kind of like not
actually if hit yeah if Hansel and
Gretel had like grown up like after they
escaped from the witch and then they
went around like hunting other witches
you know so I feel like this one took a
more classical approach although it did
change up this story a little bit but it
did have more of like a fairy tale field
wasn't an action movie it was definitely
way more of an art house movie than I
was expecting I don't know why I was
expecting it now I had a really good
score it was an eighty style almost kind
of like giallo type score or a little
bit like mandating a reminded like the
score reminded me of Managed more times
it you could there was a bunch of Giotto
throwbacks in terms of the lighting in
the architecture of the damn house it's
almost kind of like
postmodern [ __ ] witch house I liked
it I loved the witch in this Alice Krige
played her yes see same chick that
played the board Queen Susan ghost story
yeah so she's hot as an old lady she's
kind of hot as an ugly old witch too you
could tell she kind of business and they
got her oh I got a god or ugly duh but
there was something kind of sexy about
her yeah she can also she can take a
bunch of different forms including like
a hot young goth chick all tatted up and
[ __ ] as long as the one soon as the
witch showed up into the movie I liked
it but it was condom over too quick yeah
final scene the courts the witch gets
killed you know this from the front from
the fairy tale yeah they didn't go that
far gets killed
I'm like well is she coming back I want
a damn a tea stop action happening like
Terminator like with your girl's ons but
then all of a sudden she goes back and
you gotta fight it again I was waiting
for some [ __ ] like that that didn't have
there was some real good effects some
good creepy [ __ ] but it was almost a
little bit like a horror movie without a
lot of horror in it there should have
been more the story it's cut it's
convoluted I didn't understand the story
I came out of it going but I kind of
liked it and then I told Jenny what I
thought had happened and I totally
misunderstood this I thought the witch
was I thought the witch was [ __ ]
Gretel's mom now and that that Hansa was
also the kid and that she and I thought
that Gretel was the girl in the damn
pink hat who was born a witch so I I had
it all [ __ ] up and so part of that
that I'm only gonna put that on the
director I got it though you're paying
close attention and you're you write
stories and you're big into this [ __ ] if
you don't catch my attention in the
first few minutes I start kind of
ignoring what's happening I'm like yeah
just put up with it it's it's a kind of
a deal where I'm very hard to influence
I'm very strong-willed and telling a
story to someone it's a from really from
my point of view is it's a form of
influence I'm seeing the story I want I
don't really
I hear your story the only way you're
gonna get me to hear your story is to
kind of hook me into it very early and I
didn't get hooked into this until until
they got into the witch's house so
mentally I was kind of resisting the
story I guess I guess yeah because I'm
going yeah this is [ __ ] I don't like
her hair you know when is this where is
this [ __ ] what year is this Europe
didn't look like this I'm not flexible
yeah well you can't just like let [ __ ]
unfold oh no I mean it's just a story
it's not it'll like give you cancer or
anything
well when I'm first trying to establish
myself in the story I want to know is
this is this a fictionalized story as a
fiction is he trying to tell me is the
tone realism is the tone surrealism is
it fantasy and I really couldn't tell
well I just think it was [ __ ]
postmodern that's what it is because I
smarter just got I've seen this guy's
other two movies and this is similar to
ice I still like those other two movies
better this one is along the same lines
but also not quite um you know since
from the outset you know I'm approaching
this as a dark fantasy or a dark fairy
tale then I'm just gonna let it unspool
the way it wants to unspool you know
what I mean just because that's how I'm
approaching it um yes I could see if you
wanted to nitpick it's like you know why
are some of the characters have British
accents what is something quite an
American why did she have an American
accent where is this when is this I
wasn't really concerned about any of
that because like I said to me it just
seems like a fairy tale and to me a lot
of fairy tales are not super time
specific or to super location specific
so I just kind of took it in that vein
so it didn't really bother me one thing
I could have done without was her
voiceover yeah oh there's a bunch of
[ __ ] I could have done with that what
about that damn huntsman that movie was
that from I think that what they did
with that I think pretty much the sole
thing of that character because I think
a lot of the like the theme of the story
was her you know not it wasn't just the
witch that you know was bad but it's
just like the whole everybody was bad
you know
so it's kind of like everywhere was
dangerous so I think the the point of
that it was almost like and I know this
is like a weird comparison but you know
like in the Friday the 13th movies like
that weird guy that comes and says don't
go to Camp Crystal Lake was like he was
almost like that guy it was almost night
of like like introducing it's like
there's he was a good guy but he's like
oh you know from here on everyone's
gonna suck so you gotta watch out for
that so I think he was just like a
warning post yeah that guy belongs in
another movie I mean all of a sudden
you're in medieval Europe and this
[ __ ] woodsman jumps out and he's
[ __ ] speaking Shakespearean English
he's he's a black dude gives a big old
[ __ ] speech and then kills a damn
monster we're going I'm like okay this
is a main character and then vanishes
yeah throughout the rest of the movie
I'm thinking when's that Huntsman gonna
show back up he never does like what the
[ __ ] movie was that guy from he just
makes an appearance does some cool [ __ ]
and then leaves he didn't really serve a
purpose in the story I don't think
there's a lot of problems with the movie
did I did I like the witch yeah I liked
the witch I wish I wish it had been part
and there should have been that should
have been a whole movie about that witch
yeah I didn't really care about the
house on Gretel too much yeah I mean I
like the direction like I said I like
this too right I like Oz Perkins other
two movies a lot what was the whole once
one second well what was the what was
the moral of this story remember when we
watched that what was that another one
that we saw the turning yeah
the turning I thought I was watching one
movie and then the final few seconds it
told me that that it was a whole nother
movie the moral of that story was
[ __ ] be crazy okay but now I'm
reinterpreted in this one I think the
moral of this story is [ __ ] be evil
so [ __ ] be crazy [ __ ] be evil
isn't that they're talking about now cuz
they're just born like witches no no
okay well that was the whole theme of
the movie I mean the whole theme of the
movie and why it was called Gretel and
Hansel instead of the more traditional
other way around was that this was kind
of like a coming-of-age story how could
you ever own a witch they're talking
about how great it's not witchcraft is
just a metaphor it's a metaphor for evil
again No
it's not for evil that wouldn't be a
metaphor that's just a straight-up thing
it's a metaphor for coming-of-age
finding your own way in the world
finding your own power in the world the
the thing about it is that and I like
the fact that he introduced the element
into the thing where we're a Gretel also
has some kind of like witchcraft like
propensity and the witch whose name is
Holga I think I don't know if they
mentioned that the movie but um you know
she recognizes that in her and tries to
like kind of tempt her over to the dark
side and so I think that what they're
trying to say is that you know Gretel
had this power and she had the
responsibility to use it either way that
she could use it you know I mean it's
just kind of like a metaphor for finding
your own power like I said finding your
own way it's a coming-of-age story it
was too sophisticated it's just a dr.
sweetie not that sophisticated it's a
very very simple thing there's a in fact
like a lot of fairy tales have that
theme you know what I mean they're not
just like straightforward stories they
usually have a moral of some type and
that's usually what they are is they're
usually like coming-of-age stories or
you know a childhood to adulthood type
of passage which is what this was and in
a lot of ways I think this did it more
overtly than the original fairy tale we
were late we left the show and I was you
know in the car and we're talking about
it I could tell she was getting
exasperated because I didn't understand
the movie at all yeah I thought I
thought the witch was her mom no cuz
that made more sense to me based on what
I saw she was a mother figure but she
wasn't her literal mom right and I
thought it was a parallel they were
trying a parallel between the first
thing that the first thing Gretel does
is tell this story about this girl in
the pink hat yeah the most beautiful
girl in the world yeah yeah I thought
she was telling a story about herself or
something yeah that's just the way I
interpreted it so I guess I read too
much into because some movies you do
kind of do kind of to read it between
the lines but yeah they were just
drawing a parallel between Holga the
wedge and the little girl in the pink
hat and Gretel and Hansel and Gretel
being a mother to her yeah now it turns
out Gretel's of which to see so I go oh
okay she must have been the one in the
damn pink hat so
in mail logic the unit sava men have a
different logical logical mechanism of
how [ __ ] works alright that's just how I
interpreted this movie and I don't know
after you told me what it really meant I
was like okay now I don't like the movie
my prior version of it we had the same
problem with the Suspiria remake it was
very funny to me after we saw that movie
and you actually kind of liked that
movie and then turns out I know you came
across and like you got the story
totally wrong yeah I can't and I was
like no that wasn't what happened is
this than the other thing well yeah so
like I said I don't really tell me the
story if the story isn't so and this is
a convoluted [ __ ] story
it's so sighs I was Suspiria yeah okay
and well it was just one that you had to
pay attention to you have a
strong-willed people dumped to pay
attention to little details so so I'm
weak willed I don't know what it is is
that you yeah you're there to be told a
story and I'm not really there to be
told a story I guess I don't know what
what it is see that's it I something why
I said that seems very weird to me
because it's like if you're not gonna
pay attention to a movie why you just
stay home and stare at the wall well she
knows that a lot of times I would prefer
to just stay home really but I don't
know I just I'm used to stories coming
at me from a certain angle and when it
kind of defies when a story kind of
defies my kind of preset expectations I
I guess I guess subliminally just kind
of reject it just like see that's why
specifically I try not to have
expectations about something because I
want to see I'm interested to see what
other people's perspectives are that
doesn't mean that I like it or I think
it's successful there's a lot of things
about this movie I think could have been
done better like I said I could have
done without the the voiceover I don't
think it was necessary to me it seemed
like the voice-over was like a studio
thing after like no one would know
what's going on or it's too quiet or
something like that so you should like
have the character like talk over it
like [ __ ] Blade Runner and so that
was kind of annoying I didn't really
think it needed it because you I could
tell what was going on without her
saying so that could have been and like
I said there were a couple elements that
you know maybe could have been you know
done better but
the whole I feel like this is probably
gonna be very divisive but I liked that
it was it was an interesting experiment
it was like you know like I said it was
way more arthouse and I was expecting it
had like a lot more it's not super gory
or super but it had like some really
good like gore set pieces that have like
some really really creepy imagery like I
said it Oh Marsh Suspiria a little
shout-out to Wizard of Oz in there I
heard that like right at the end you
know there was some cool [ __ ] in this
I'd like I said I didn't like it as much
as his other two movies because I loved
his other two movies so I didn't like it
as much as that but as a fairy tale
adaptation I thought it was actually
pretty cool and I thought it was like an
interesting direction to go in you know
I think it had some cool ideas I really
like the stuff they had to head to which
it is she did a great job and she was
the been about to use only some of the
ideas of like the front of certain
powers that she had and how she did that
[ __ ] though I was like lost that's all
right you know I'd like to see a whole
movie with that yeah yeah but the but
just from the perspective of just like
Joe Blow you're you're some swing and
dick sitting in the audience you don't
know like this movie no probably not
I feel like this is not gonna be for
general law but man if you're a man if
your main man what's that one what's
that song that I'm gonna get into he's a
man anyway
know if you used to regular dude you're
not gonna like this movie well yeah like
I said I think it's gonna be buried in
people that are into our in-house movies
like I am I you know like I said I
didn't like it as much as other ones but
there was some interesting [ __ ] in there
and I really liked a lot of the imagery
and I I do think it needed more which
because really like the best scenes like
once they got to the witch's house and
like there were the scenes between
Gretel and the witch and they were like
just talking and like [ __ ] was going on
and some of the Summa Gretel's like
weird visions and dreams or whatever um
that was the best [ __ ] I would like to
see several witches like that fight each
other alright watch a witch is fighting
and then like they make some vampires
and the vampires fight and they write on
dinosaur ID on some [ __ ] dinosaurs
with explosive Dyer and at the very end
the witch gets [ __ ] big like a size
like a big magic like
like a dinosaur size of Godzilla that
would be kind of funny that sounds like
a Chuck tingle storm yeah like she's
fighting [ __ ] pounded in the butt by
my which dinosaur wasn't quite knights
in armor and [ __ ] orcs is [ __ ] yeah
so Lord of the Rings is what you want
yeah I didn't like this [ __ ] hobbits
are looking at each other too much oh
gee I liked the the trilogy that they
made of The Hobbit why I thought was
just like unforgivable hobbits are
looking at each other like get a [ __ ]
room man I thought they were gonna [ __ ]
at any moment you see that [ __ ] a lot of
people have said that I don't remember I
don't really remember I saw Lord of the
Rings like one time the movies and I
liked him but I didn't really
yeah The Hobbit ones I saw the first one
I was like man [ __ ] that cuz I loved
that book when I was a kid and it's like
it didn't need three movies they're like
adding so much stuff to it and the CGI
was really bad I'd like to see there
which which in the in the Terminator but
the old Terminator back went back when
Oliver was a man I you know what I
almost feel like the witch in this could
maybe kick the terminators ass yeah I
were just making judge she was she was
actually really like I said Alice Creech
there's like there's a reason why they
cast her is like the shape-shifting
demon in ghost story and why she was the
Borg Queen and stuff like that she has
like a really otherworldly kind of
quality about her there's something very
unsettling about her and that which was
taken [ __ ] human body parts and
putting a spell on him to make him look
like delicious foods and she was feeding
it to the kid I'm [ __ ] little girls
hair yeah that's on the poster actually
like her pulling that little braid as
well that's pretty good there she had a
long animal and poured herself down a
drain can you idea I I need to like to
see more of that yeah there was like I
said there was some really cool ideas on
that I don't think it gelled completely
and there was some things that I would
change but because he had a good idea
for a witch but then it got kind of
stuffed into a [ __ ] Hansel and Gretel
mold [ __ ] Hansel and Gretel man that
that story is too limited true although
like I said oh sorry but yeah yeah
it was within the confines of that that
story yeah and and then he had to kind
of twist the story to make the story
interesting because that's not an
interesting story she should have had a
witch in another context should've been
a bunch of witches fighting like yeah
man I'm [ __ ] not lying if we're making
all kinds of money right now what did
she write that it would be made about
you write it it would be making all
kinds of money I don't want to see it
much good to be making all kinds of
money sitting back there making all
kinds of money right now if it was about
a bunch of witches fighting I don't know
man I just really like that the distant
and the witches are like in a mafia it's
like a coven but it's like a mafia and
it's like different covens fighting each
other well yeah you write it like The
Godfather but it's about witches and
it's kind of like the Sith you SIF
versus SIF you know and there are no
good people in it evil is that I haven't
read them for a while but anne rice's
you know which chronicles or whatever
they um they were kind of like that in
the sense that it was like kind of
warring like which families yeah it I'm
surprised that they never made any
movies to see you know in a witch story
now I'm gonna go full balls to the walls
there's not gonna be any good people in
it they're all gonna be bad yeah this is
gonna be like the real world where it's
not good against evil it's just evil
against evil yeah I mean just gangs
against like did they do it in the Mafia
flicks yeah I do the witches yes sir
like I said I haven't seen like a lot of
stuff so there might already be
something like that yeah I mean I'm sure
if you look long enough he could find
something just like way yeah but yet men
and and children and [ __ ] like that yeah
I'd probably watch them yeah I guess
there's no men in there yeah yeah they
like hate men that's the way I would do
it make it real [ __ ] scary yeah and
the only man that senior as a damn
vampire yeah he fights them too you know
that's pretty cool but yeah so like I
said I'm imagining I'm telling you it's
cool imagine my story not an ounce of
soy in my movie yeah okay so anyway yeah
so if you like oz Parkins you and if you
like kind of dark fairy tale movie
should probably check it out like I said
it's very arthouse so if you're not into
that kind of stuff then you're probably
not gonna dig it it's only 87 minutes
long it's actually actually it
she felt really short to me it didn't
but you know actually I even though like
some of it was quote unquote slow-moving
I should've said Metz that which [ __ ]
[ __ ] up I loved it I do think it did it
didn't need more wish just because she
was [ __ ] great I mean she was like
the best character and there's really
only three characters in this like three
main cares and they show everyone inside
her house is pretty weird - it should
have showed us even more and more of the
Sphinx kitty yes st. Kitty's hidden
doors traps [ __ ] vampires a bunch of
bunch of bodies in there just everything
yeah I'm just giving you a man's point
of view so anyway yeah this is playing
at the theater so I'll go check it out
if you're interested
[Music]